Hello, I'm Brian Stockton and I'm the committee chair for PAC 38 in Des Moines, Iowa.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks, Clark,
I appreciate everything you do.
And now to you, Scoutmaster.
A Scout walks into the room for his Eagle border review.
He's introduced. everybody in the border review sits down at the table.
They're looking through the papers and they look at him and they say, well, what about
some personal references?
And the Eagle Scout looks at the border review members and says, no, you guys look pretty
trustworthy to me,
I don't really need any references
There you go
Right,
Clever Eagle Scout.
Hey, this is podcast number 293..
Hey
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green
And over in the mailbag this week John Clements gave us a five star review of So Far, So Good
on Amazon.
So Far, So Good is a book, a very simple narrative about a new Scoutmaster who's trying to
get his troop a little back more on True North, running the patrol method, youth leadership-
pretty familiar story.
But over on Amazon John said it's great storyline that covers the transformation
from adult to scout led troop.
For me the best parts are how to work with adults, which is where the real challenge in
this transformation will be found.
Well, that's true, John,
And what I did in writing the book was trying to create a narrative that helped think through
a lot of issues: working with the Scouts, working with their families, working with
some of your fellow Scouters.
So thanks very much, John, for that review over on Amazon.
I really appreciate it.
Matt Thompson is with Troop 216 in Eureka, Kansas,
And he said: I listened to podcast 282 about removing problematic volunteers
And you're correct:
The chartered organization representative is going to be the person who will help you
out.
There is a small section related to this in the commissioner fieldbook
And I've attached the relevant pages for you to share,
And I appreciate that, Matt.
I will have a link to a PDF version of those pages on the post that contains
this podcast.
If you'll keep an eye on our Twitter feed and our Facebook feed, every week we
have a couple of live chat sessions, usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings,
And lots of folks show up for the live chat sessions over at scoutmastercgcom.
Sometimes we chat about things of major importance
And sometimes we just we just chat.
So come on over to scoutmastercgcom,
Keep an eye on the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed,
Join us in a live chat this week, like Kevin Brew did.
He's a scout leader and assistant island commissioner.
Wow, how about that?
There's not too many island commissioners out there for scouts on the Isle of
Man and that's in the middle of the Irish Sea between Ireland and England.
Kevin is on the Isle of Man and he's a part of the UK Scout Association
And he joined us for our live chat this week, along with all the other
frequent flyers who show up for our live chat sessions.
So come on, you never know who you're going to meet on the live chat
Over on Facebook this past week and on the blog, let's see.
The big thing was the eight knot contest infographic that we created this week.
I'm sure that there are lots of other versions of a similar kind of contest
out there, but it's a great individual contest or
an inter patrol competition
Got a lot of attention over on Facebook this week.
Before we go any further, I want to ask you to do something for me.
It's pretty simple.
If you're a regular reader and listener and the resources that I've created have
helped you, I'm asking you return the favor by becoming a ScoutmasterCGcom
backer.
Funds we get from our backers go to cover all the expenses of producing and
publishing everything at ScoutmasterCGcom, including the podcast you're
listening to right now,
And we keep it freely available for everybody all over the world.
Here's what you do:
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom, click the support link at the top of the page
And you can choose from a number of options there, which include autograph
copies of my books like so far, so good. that I mentioned a little bit earlier,
And I want to take a moment to personally thank Brian Stockton, Brian Stone
and Brad Watts, who all have become backers since our last podcast.
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom, click the support link at the top of the page,
Become a backer this week and I'll make sure to thank you personally on our
next podcast.
One last thing before we get going here I want to mention I'll be spending
a week in Kondersteg, Switzerland, at the International Scout Center next
July.
I'm going to be hosting anyone who'd like to come over and see Switzerland
and experience the kind of mini international jamboree over at
Kondersteg. get in touch with me about it.
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom.
You'll see a link in the menu to Kondersteg 2016..
Come on and join us.
It's going to be great fun.
Well, in the remainder of this week's podcast in Scout MasterChip
in seven minutes or less. I want to share with you some thoughts
about peace scouting and the kind of opportunities that we have
as scouters to promote peace.
And this is based on an address that Baden Powell delivered to what
would become the World Organization of the Scouting Movement in 1922
in Paris.
And then I have a couple of email questions to answer.
So let's get started. shall we
Scout MasterChip in seven minutes or less?
Since the podcast last week, the world
is reeling from the latest episode of terrorism that
unfolded in Paris, France,
And that all too familiar specter of fear and foreboding
is blanketing all of our news coverage.
But if you're a scouter, you get to respond to what
happened in Paris this week when you
go to open the door of the room where your scouts are
going to meet, because you have the opportunity
to have a profound effect on the collective future
of humanity.
Sounds like a big order, doesn't it?
But it's actually pretty simple.
The idea I want to share with you isn't new
And it isn't especially complicated,
And because it's neither new or complicated,
it's going to sound a little trite,
But don't be fooled.
This is a profound and inspiring opportunity
for every scouter in every part of the world
Scouting's founder, Robert Baden Powell,
shared this very simple idea in an address to what
would become the World Organization of the Scouting
Movement in 1922 at the Sorbonne University there
in Paris,
In the very city that has been just reeling
from these acts of terrorism. many years ago, there
was Baden Powell at the world famous Sorbonne
University delivering an address about education in love
in place of fear.
Imagine for a moment 1922 in world history.
Humanity is still reeling from the tragedy of World War
I. Baden Powell himself, his own personal history,
tells us that he has an intimate personal knowledge
of war during his long service as a British officer
in the Boer Wars.
And in his address he says, quote:
I've spent a good part of my life as a soldier
And I've seen something of the brutality and horrors
incidental to this man-authorized murder
of God's creatures, our brother men,
together with the ruin of their homes and the sufferings
of the innocent women and children.
And it is in this historic backdrop,
not only of what's happening in world affairs in 1922,
but Baden Powell's own personal history,
that he steps onto the stage at the Sorbonne
University in Paris and shares these thoughts.
He begins by stating that fear is what
compels mankind and nations to harm each other.
And that fear quote-
has been the weapon of the powerful
in terrorizing the weaker. unquote.
He follows by observing that quote:
love is what we all pray for, yet we allow ourselves
to live under the yoke of fear.
And he insists that if we imply love in place of fear,
we gain peace, mutual trust, honor and goodwill.
And it goes on to note something very counterintuitive:
The world's just been through World War I,
but there's rising militarism amongst the nations of Europe
in the wake of that war based on fear.
But Baden Powell, in his address, suggests
that there is an alternative for militarism.
He says there's a way for every nation
to have strong, character-driven young people,
confident in themselves, resilient, educated,
compassionate people who will fix the world.
He continues by saying- quote:
this may seem to be a utopian dream,
too visionary and too impractical,
And he asks: can it ever be brought about in practice?
And then he answers his own question: yes,
because through scouting it's already happening
in every corner of the world.
And that's where you and I come in.
We can apply love in the place of fear. sometime this week
We can take part in creating strong,
character-driven young people, confident in themselves,
resilient, educated and compassionate people
who will fix the world.
When we turn the key on the meeting room door
and our scouts fill the room,
we're unlocking an opportunity to apply love
in the place of fear.
And our dens and patrols and crews,
scouts, work together and learn that they can get along,
that they can resolve their differences peacefully
and they can be of service to the greater circles
of their family, their community,
their nation and their world.
In the course of the last week
there have been some events
that make us feel uncertain and fearful,
But you know, it's kind of hard to find a time
in human history where there wasn't a good excuse
to feel uncertain and fearful every single day.
But the simple truth is that as scouts,
we build our world in comparatively small
but incredibly important ways
by forming character, compassion
and the ideal of service in our scouts.
Your opportunity as a scouter is very profound.
Take a moment today and think about that,
because we join hands with millions
of fellow scouts around the world
working to educate in love in place of fear.
As I said at the beginning,
it's a simple idea,
It's nothing new, but it's so very, very important
because we all have plenty of work left to do.
I need your letter, send it by name
Email. that is, folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Ty Williams is the scout master of Troop 262
in Clarkston Washington.
Our troop rechartered last September
after it was leaderless for about a year.
So all of the scouts in my troop are pretty young.
Many crossed over as weeblos and the oldest is 12..
There are a couple of groups of siblings
who argue a lot at troop meetings and campouts
and everywhere.
Now, is this just because they're siblings
or is there really something I can do
In addition to that? I'm not really sure
about what I can do to teach my scouts the values
that will help them avoid the problems I see
in my professional life as a social worker.
It all feels a little overwhelming.
It feels like I'm trying to fight lots
of negative influences in the wider society
and I'm really not too sure where to begin.
Well, Ty, it sounds like you have a fantastic opportunity
and you're gonna have a fantastic time.
I envy you really
Having a group of young scouts
basically restarting a troop. you're gonna do fine.
So let me offer you some basic advice.
First off, just relax a little bit. okay,
You're gonna be a good scouter and it's challenging.
Sure, there's lots of things to do
and lots of things to think about,
but when you come down to it, it's pretty simple.
Secondly, I want to advise you
to meet your scouts where they are
and help them find their way forward.
And to meet them where they are.
you're gonna have to ask them lots of questions
and listen carefully to what they have to say.
Begin to understand something about them,
about what they're thinking about
their families and their homes,
about the way that they interact in their community.
And then, third, remember what it's like to be their age
Now. who really helped when you were that old
and who didn't?
And I'm gonna guess that the folks that really helped you.
you may not remember exactly what they said
or even exactly how they did it,
but you remember how they made you feel.
So what you do as a scouter is all about
your perspective and your attitude.
You're serving your scouts. that's your attitude,
and your perspective is understanding something about them
and meeting them where they are
Now. fourth, you can't really fight negative influences
in the lives of your scouts,
and you don't wanna fight them,
because you're always gonna lose.
What you can do is offer something better
in a way that they can understand
in a way that's accessible to your scouts,
and trust them to make the right decision,
because all of us, when we see something better,
when we see something that is not negative,
that's positive. when we find positive ways
to grow and to live and to work with people,
we're gonna choose the positive things.
So don't worry about fighting negative influences.
you don't have to.
What you need to do is emphasize
the positive influences in their lives.
And then, last but not least,
look, do not attempt to teach them anything,
because you're not a teacher.
Don't do anything the teachers do,
because if you do, they're gonna put up
their defensive shield that they have perfected
in long years of schooling.
Instead of trying to teach them anything,
make opportunities for them to teach themselves,
Ask questions and follow up with more questions.
Soon they're gonna learn to ask questions of themselves
and really start learning how to learn,
which is the greatest gift we can give any of our scouts.
And oh, you talked about siblings arguing,
and you know what. you're not gonna be able
to do too much about that by coming at it as a problem. okay,
What you're gonna find is
is that your scouts are going to do
whatever gets your attention
If you pay a lot of attention to arguing,
they're gonna continue to argue.
If you point out and celebrate
even the smallest indication of these siblings
getting along and expressing courtesy
and friendship and kindness,
they're going to outdo each other in those things.
So, Ty, once again I envy you.
It sounds like a great time.
And keep it really simple.
It's all about your attitude and your perspective.
and listen carefully to what your scouts have to say.
The next email: well, it's another younger scout question
and the person who sent me the email
asked to remain anonymous-
Says: I have a lot of newer scouts.
I have 10 or so newer scouts
and of those scouts,
three are just straight up troublemakers.
They're basically very undisciplined.
They run all around,
They don't listen to our youth leadership,
They're loud and they're literally ruining the meetings
for the other scouts that want to be there.
I looked at your site for some help.
I found a lot of things undisciplined,
but I wanna give my senior patrol leader
and the patrol leaders council
a couple of articles or a podcast
so they can get some good ideas to rein these boys in.
The older scouts have some ideas
about disciplining these guys
and we have spoken to their parents.
and now I wanna discuss proper conduct
in a troop meeting setting.
So any help or advice you have would be appreciated.
Well, when it comes down to difficult behavior in scouts,
I have a pretty simple formula.
First off, you don't want youth leaders
disciplining scouts or having to deal with
all but the most garden variety
kinds of difficult behavior.
There is a base expectation for participating in scouts
and that is that you conduct yourself
in a way consistent with the scout oath and law.
Now, garden variety misbehavior
is gonna be somebody having a bad day
and getting a little stroppy,
or somebody making a bad choice about something,
and a lot of those things. yes,
our youth leadership can deal with them,
but when it is a repeated pattern of difficult behavior-
that's one of the reasons that scouts are there.
Scouts who can't behave
or follow directions from youth leaders
are gonna get referred to you as the scout master
and you establish some very simple things
in a very brief and simple conversation.
You tell them individually:
don't do this with groups of scouts,
only with individual scouts.
You tell them that they will follow the directions
of their youth leaders
and conduct themselves as scouts
according to the oath and law.
That's the expectation you have
and then ask them to tell you what that means
and listen carefully while they explain it to you.
Now you may have to ask a few more questions
and focus in on a couple of points
of the scout oath and law,
but once they have told you
what they understand about
what your expectations of behavior is,
then you say okay.
so we both understand what's expected of you.
and let me explain what happens
if you and I end up having to discuss this again
because you aren't keeping up your end of the bargain
and conducting yourself as a scout.
If you can't behave,
what'll happen is you'll have to come
and sit over here quietly
until your parents come to pick you up,
and then you and I and your parents
are gonna have a talk.
I will tell them that they have to keep you home
from scouts until they can tell me
that you will behave and follow directions
and conduct yourself according to the scout oath and law,
because none of our youth leaders discipline
or punish scouts. none of our scouts, myself included,
discipline or punish scouts.
that is your family's job.
So if you can't behave,
I will tell them that they have to fix the problem
at home before you can come back.
So it's a pretty matter of fact, discussion
and we make sure the scout understands
exactly what we've said.
and there you go
A lot of times
the idea that their parents are gonna get involved
or that they're going to have to miss out on scouts
because their behavior problem
will fix the behavior.
Sometimes it won't,
and you have to be open to having discussions
with the scout, with his parents,
and simply drawing the line at the idea
that you are going to engage
in any kind of discipline or punishment.
Now, having a scout correct anything
that is the result of his misbehavior
in proportionate consequences,
now that's not punishment, right?
So what I'm saying is:
let's say a scout makes a mess of something, right?
Well, he cleans up the mess.
That's proportionate consequences,
but it's not punishment.
So you draw the line at punishment.
If a scout has a continuous pattern and misbehavior,
then he's referred to you by the youth leadership
and you refer him to his parents and you say:
look, we have a very high expectation of behavior here
and this isn't just simply one mistake
or two mistakes or three mistakes.
This is a pretty much a pattern and we can't have it.
So here's our plan:
You're gonna take him home
and you as a family have to solve the behavior problem
before he's able to come back here.
And it's really simple: mom and dad,
you just tell me that you've corrected the problem
and he's welcome back to scouts.
But we draw the line:
We don't punish scouts, we don't discipline scouts,
because we believe that's family's responsibility.
And I know I've mentioned all this before
and we've talked about conduct and rules
and things like that.
And if you go to scoutmastercgcom
and you go to the index and you look at the articles
and podcasts we've done on discipline
before, that kind of help answer some of the questions
that this particular answer might create for you.
But it's actually pretty simple.
The real breakthrough for me on this was figuring out
that scouts and youth leaders do not punish
or discipline scouts and that there was no acceptable level
of absolute misbehavior or a pattern of misbehavior
that we needed to put up with
and that it was the job of their families
to take care of those issues.
Hey, if you have a question for me,
you can get in touch.
It's pretty easy to do
And I'm gonna tell you how to make that happen
in just a moment.
Well, thanks for listening to this 293rd edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
To keep in touch, go to scoutmastercgcom.
You can read the blog and if you look at the index
you'll find 16 or 1700 different podcasts,
articles, infographics, all kinds of great stuff.
And while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog and the podcast by email.
You can also experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
with lots of pals through the vast panorama
of social media.
You can join the 10,800- some folks
who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
You can tweet along with the chorus of 1,300 or so
tweeters on Twitter.
You can pin the Pultritudinous pictures
that we proffer publicly with 2,300 other
prolific pinners on Pinterest.
You can watch us at scoutmastercg on YouTube.
But if none of that makes sense to you,
if you can't face Facebook and Twitter makes you better,
you have no interest in Pinterest.
if you don't put the? U in YouTube,
just zoom into the late 90s and fire off an email.
You can get in touch with me,
Clark Green, at Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
If all else fails, set your secret decoder ring pin
to B2 and listen carefully to Pierre Andre's instructions
during the next Orphan Annie broadcast.
By now it should be abundantly clear
that the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of anybody in particular
other than myself.
We are not sponsored or endorsed
by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization.
No, it's really just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to Scouters
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun,
our founder, Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.